uh the border patrol again have said in
no uncertain terms to all of us and i
hope to many of you that should that
happen they will lose operational
control of the border
right now there are about 8 000 people a
day coming through the border
they believe that if title 42
is revoked that that number will
increase dramatically department of
homeland security has told us privately
that they think that's between 12 000
and 18 000 people a day
so uh this is just impossible for
the border patrol to handle
the title 42 issue to set the stage here
for my colleagues and their remarks
is in litigation
there's a judge in louisiana who said
that the administration cannot simply
revoke this
but they have not set a date as to what
might be the appropriate time frame
if there is one so there's a lot of
uncertainty right now certainly but
we have to presume that the
administration
may be successful here and that means
title 42 would come to an end
roughly half of the people who come to
the border are turned away under title
42
roughly half
so the million people a year is really 2
million people a year about a million
are turned back under title 42.
we also know that the public health
emergency and the national emergencies
act
are continuing in place indefinitely
so there seems to be a real disconnect
between what's happening with regard to
title 42 on the one hand and the public
health emergencies on the other hand
this is a situation that again is
already a crisis
already something that we cannot handle
with current resources
yesterday we had a conference call with
the secretary of homeland security uh
alejandro mjorkas
in which he laid out a potential plan
um
should title 42 be revoked
it sounds a lot like the plan currently
in place which is
simply to expedite people coming through
the process
no plan to
put in place the kinds of things that
were in place during the trump
administration to try to deal with the
border crisis including the remain of
mexico policy the expedited removals
the notion that with regard to asylum
there would be
more scrutiny earlier in the process
but instead just coming up with a way to
provide more resources to move people
through the system more quickly so in
effect to
to make it easier for people to get from
the border into the interior of the
country so that was disappointing
i'm really glad again my colleagues are
all here and a lot of them have been
down to the border as i have and heard
directly from the border patrol and
customs and border protection folks at
the ports of entry to understand the
severity of this crisis i'd like for you
to hear from them now senator barrasso
well we actually have a dangerous crisis
of national security going on in the
border and it's going to get a lot worse
under joe biden from day number one joe
biden started rolling out the red carpet
to illegal immigrants by signing so many
executive orders specifically making it
easier for illegal immigrants to come to
the united states
the number of people that came into the
united states illegally in the first 14
months of joe biden was more than came
in under four years
of president trump and we're talking
about 2 million crossings last year
and if title 42 goes along we're talking
about over 500 000
expected next month
alone
and if the numbers are alone aren't
distressing enough is taking a look at
who some of these people are in terms of
criminals drug dealers gang members
and if you're on the terrorist watch
list this is a dream come true for you
if you're trying to get into the united
states illegally
now we have a number of democrats who
are now running away from the president
these are democrats who are running for
reelection and they're running scared
because they know the president's
policies on immigration are so very
unpopular
but president biden has turned over
the border
and his policies on immigration to
people who really don't believe there
should be even be a border
i mean even the vice president of the
united states when she was running for
president
said she wanted to eliminate
immigrations and customs enforcement
we know what we need to do to secure the
border enforce the law
finish the wall
reestablish the remain in mexico policy
it works
title 42 is about public health and
public safety
and the president is talking out of both
sides of his mouth on this
because in one regard he's saying he
need he asked for 25 billion additional
additional dollars for covid
because covet is such a crisis in the
united states right now
and at the same time on the other side
of his mouth he said oh
covet is done we don't have to worry
about it with regard to the border we
can make it a lot easier for illegal
immigrants to come to this country
when we talked yesterday a number of us
in leadership on the conference call
with us with the
secretary of homeland security
the plan he laid out
was to allow illegal immigrants to come
here faster and easier
not to keep them out
so for people who believe like i do we
have a dramatic and desperate crisis
of national security at our southern
border i will tell you if they eliminate
title 42 it's going to get a lot worse
thanks
well thanks rob
we are a nation of laws we're a nation
of immigrants
but the one thing that we have to have
in this country is respect for our laws
and this is
the biden border
crisis no ifs ands and buts about it
there has never been a more direct
correlation between a set of policy
decisions
and consequences resulting from those
decisions than what we've seen at the
border
when they came to office they got rid of
94 they took 94 executive actions they
got rid of the tools
that enabled our border patrol to keep
the border secure and what have we seen
2 million
illegal crossings last year
221 000 last month the highest number in
22 years
and we're told that if title 42 goes
away
we're looking at 18 000
a day
compared to sixteen hundred per day
pre-pandemic
these are staggering numbers
and we're also told that by the border
patrol that nine out of ten agents
will be taken off the border
and used to process migrants
what does that do to all the other
unsavory things that are happening at
the border senator portman mentioned a
number of those but the biggest killer
today of people between the ages of 18
and 45 is fentanyl
and fentanyl is coming across the border
because it's just essentially an open
border
and so we've got the we've got the the
direct consequence of these byte
administration policies playing out in
front of the american people on a daily
basis
and what have they done well they've
stopped construction the border walls
senator barroso pointed out
they have significantly curbed
deportations they have ended the
remaining mexico policy these are all
policy decisions taken by executive
action by an administration which is yet
to visit the border so the via the
president and his borders are the vice
president
are directly responsible for what is
happening at our southern border and
title 42 makes it much much worse if
they end that if they repeal title 42 as
they are intending to do
it is going to intensify and make much
worse a problem that is already of epic
proportions in terms of the disaster
that we're seeing there on a daily basis
so i you know the democrats in the
senate at least are coming to
realization i think in the house as well
that this is a really bad idea and
they're conveying that
i think to the administration hopefully
the administration will listen
because
if they move forward with this policy it
will be on top of a whole bunch of other
bad policies that have contributed to a
major crisis at our southern border and
republicans in the senate are going to
insist on a vote
we want to vote we want to put people on
the record whether or not they support
this
really awful decision by this
administration
to backtrack yet again on a border
policy
that is at least had some success
in controlling and keeping the number of
illegal crossings somewhat under control
but it will explode it will flat explode
if they move forward so we'll do
everything we can to to stop that and
republicans in the senate are going to
assist insist upon a vote on title 42
and i hope i hope sincerely hope that
we'll have a lot of democrats who will
join us
this is policy insanity
the body administration is getting the
immigration policy that they designed
they stripped away all the restrictions
for actually people crossing the border
they get this result now with record
high numbers of people illegally
crossing the border now they're saying
and we're going to drop title 42 as well
so we get record high numbers now of
illegal crossings and they're going to
say we're going to strip away the last
piece that we hadn't taken away before
to increase this number even higher
now remind everyone that's here of the
simple fact the 221 thousand encounters
as they called them from the last month
is a record high number what people are
not talking about as well are the 66 000
what they call got aways that also
happened last month that is the border
patrol were so active trying to round up
and engage this group of 221 000 they
could see in the distance and count
people crossing the border there were 66
000 that we had no contact with that we
literally watched them come across the
border
who's crossing the border and what's
happening at this point
was people from 157 different countries
just in the last six months that have
crossed the border
none of these individuals have a
criminal background check actually
carried out on them from their home
country they're doing a criminal
background check if they've committed a
crime in the united states before but we
have no idea
in the country they're coming from if
there's a criminal background at all and
for the sixty six thousand got aways
that happened just last month we have no
criminal background check in this
country or in their previous country
this is opening up our nation to
additional crime while the american
people are literally saying let's deal
with the crime problem the biden
administration is opening up the border
more
and having even more people across the
border
with no check
with no evaluation of their previous
history at all
this is why i say it is policy insanity
what they're doing
the plan that we were given yesterday
this planned statement that came in from
alejandro mayorkas
this plane that was supposed to define
out for us is not a plane at all
it's basically how they're going to move
people into the country faster it notes
things like currently they're releasing
people into the country and giving them
eight years before there's a hearing
they're going to now just catch and
release people the same at a faster pace
moving them into the country and say now
you've got to check in within a year
but there is no evaluation there's no
chase on those individuals that they
don't check in so whether it's an
eight-year time period whether it is now
or whether they magically move that to a
one-year time period there's no change
fascinatingly enough in this report
they say they're lifting title 42
authority at the border because there's
no covet at the border but they can't
detain individuals
because there's covet in their detention
facilities so there's no covid when
you're crossing the border but if you
actually hold people in detention then
there's mass covid so we can't actually
hold people in detention so they don't
increase bed space at all in this
process
that's a major problem and can i tell
you if you read through the report and i
hope you do from what they call a
supposed plan this is not a plan this is
just what they plan to be able to carry
out to do to increase the numbers even
more it's not a plan to decrease the
numbers and i can say that not based on
my opinion but based on theirs go to the
back of their reported their supposed
plan on this they end with their
conclusion statement may i read this to
you the conclusion statement says
despite the best efforts of our
dedicated dhs workforce and our partners
executing this comprehensive plan a
significant increase in migrant
encounters will substantially strain our
system even further
so their plan is not to reduce the
number of people crossing their plan is
this is about to get worse
and we're aware that this is about to
get worse
this is not a plan to stop illegal
immigration this is a plan to accelerate
illegal immigration and they even admit
it
this has got to stop
the american people just want the
enforcement of our laws that is not too
much to ask
well thank you all for being here and
thank you rob for spearheading this um
well we've been here before we've been
talking about this is at least the
second or third press conference that
i've been a party of to talk and and a
cautionary tale as to what we see
over the horizon and the administration
by their own admission by numbers as
james said
they are uh they are acknowledging uh
that it's uh it will occur so here we go
again here we go again but there's a
couple differences
significantly as senator portman
mentioned
our colleagues on the other side of the
aisle in growing numbers are imploring
the president to um postpone
to relook
and to rethink the decision to uh
get rid of title 42 in may
and so we see those numbers i think as
as we get closer to the date we know
these numbers are going to go up but we
also have our friends in the media that
would not normally be uh
rising to to
put on their opinion pages things that
we agree with maybe here we got the
washington post a migrant surge is
coming at the border and biden is not
ready that was in april of this year and
then we have a
npr that says what happens at the border
once it is left
once it is lifted tied for 42 in a word
influx
that's a mild word i think compared to
what we think will happen and no will
happen it's going to be a catastrophe
and
senator lankford senator portman and
senator thune we were on this call
yesterday with um
the administra the secretary mayorkas
and when we talked afterwards you know
six-point plan as james was pointing out
it it's it's only a way to manage the
num more and more numbers that are
coming and it isn't really managing it's
transportation it's healthcare it's
moving people from actually the border
into into more central parts and then
processing them there what's that going
to do
that's going to keep you all away from
the processing centers of where all of
this is really occurring in my view
that's duck in the media in my view
and the and and ducking what the real
numbers could and will be
so i'm the ranking member on the
appropriations committee for homeland
security we've been very generous with
homeland security we've provided them
with already with a supplemental to help
them deal with the surge but this surge
was
here
when we see
what's going to be the influx or
catastrophe as i would uh categorize it
that is another
press
on the appropriations and on the
resources
that we're going to be willing to look
at and give to the department of
homeland security so um
i think and and i asked i specifically
asked the the secretary that question
are you looking for another supplemental
and he very artfully answered uh sort of
a maybe i think would be a good a good
way to characterize
the way he answered that very
discouragingly so i joined with my
colleagues with my democrat colleagues
with those in the media with my folks at
home are very concerned about this why
would somebody in west virginia be
worried about this because we have the
highest percentage of deaths from
overdose that per capita than any other
state in the union fentanyl is killing
our friends and neighbors and it's all
coming through the southern border so
the diversion of agents and they're
losing agents because the morale is
terrible
why would you want to be protecting our
southern borders and be prideful of what
you're doing in law enforcement every
day when your president
is just letting you get overrun
you can't divert you can't disrupt the
drug trade because you're so busy
processing and doing all of the things
that happens when eighteen thousand
people come across the border every
single day
so there's time mr president to rethink
this there's time for us to find a
better way and we've the plan
needs to be deterrence
uh whether it's uh expedited removals
uh quick uh asylum um
adjudication to get to get that the
remain in mexico policy we have some
solutions here that worked under the
trump administration to keep these
numbers down it's time now to look
seriously at these before this
catastrophe descends upon us thank you
thank you
rob
right now we've got a crisis at our
southern border
it is chaos
it is endangering the safety and
security of americans
we are seeing hundreds of thousands of
children
being brought in by human traffickers
many of them subject
to violent abuse to sexual abuse
we're seeing
criminals
violent criminals we're seeing gang
members
we're seeing people who are
known terrorists coming in illegally
this chaos is the result of political
decisions made
by joe biden kamala harris
looking at the chaos at the southern
border only this administration would
decide it's not bad enough
that we have the highest rate of illegal
immigration in 61 years 2 million people
last year
it's not bad enough
they want to make it worse
by rescinding the use of title 42
to protect against covid19 infections
it's interesting that on april 1st
the cdc issued a statement urging the
end of title 42 saying quote
after considering current public health
conditions and an increased availability
of tools to fight covet 19 such as
highly effective vaccines and
therapeutics
the cdc director has determined that an
order suspending the right to introduce
migrants into the united states is no
longer necessary
12 days later on april 13th the same cdc
extended the order that everyone must
wear masks on airplanes
so here's the biden administration's
reasoning
it's just fine according to the cdc for
tens of thousands of illegal aliens to
be released who may well have covet 19
to surge into texas communities where
the hospitals
are overrun they are full
where the schools are full where the
jails are full
but american citizens even those who
have been vaccinated
even those who have had kobe they must
wear a mask it is utterly arbitrary and
hypocritical now thankfully both of
those decisions
the decision to end the use of title 42
and the arbitrary decision to require
everyone to wear masks on planes both of
them
the federal courts have stopped
but the partisan hypocrisy
is stunning this is the cdc
embracing open borders
and i will say partisan hypocrisy
capitol hill is certainly not immune
from that particular
failing
we're now seeing a bunch of democrats
interestingly enough
all collected in states
where they're on the ballot in november
and they've suddenly discovered the
american people don't like it when you
have two million illegal immigrants when
you're releasing vast numbers of people
in chaos and so suddenly you've got
democrats who are releasing statements
saying
we should not
end title 42.
the hypocrisy of that is last year i
forced a vote on my amendment
to codify
the protections of title 42 to stop the
administration from ending title 42 and
every
single democrat
voted no every one of the democrats is
putting out press statements so the
press statements are actually very
convenient
because the corporate media will happily
parrot that they oppose ending title 42
while ignoring the fact that when they
had the chance to actually do something
about it
every single democrat voted no and by
the way
many of us have been fighting to get
another vote on title 42
and chuck schumer is blocking the vote
because he doesn't want to vote
to put people on record
this is extreme
it's radical
it's dangerous
and it's unnecessary
the open border policies of this
administration
are a disaster and i'll tell you
my prediction is in november
south texas is turning bright red
south texas has been a heavily democrat
region of our state for a hundred plus
years
this november i think we're going to
elect republican members of congress i
think we've got a good shot at electing
two or even three hispanic women
republicans to represent south texas
because i can tell you when i sit down
at round tables in south texas
elected democrats tell me if my party is
the party of open borders i can't
support that
this is a disaster and it is caused by
joe biden and kamala harris
well this administration is either
incompetent or they want this crisis it
has to be one or the other either
they're incompetent or they want this
crisis
i think we all realize that if we repeal
title 42 if we implement dhs's plan
we're going to double or triple the
number of people coming across the
border in the next few months
we've done over 90 town halls in kansas
now since being sworn in a little bit
over a year ago and i can assure
everybody that their biggest concerns
are inflation and the safety and
security of their families
and their safety starts at this open
southern border
i want to bring this issue home to
kansas we're not a border state in case
you didn't have geography we're in the
heartland the very middle of the country
and this is the front page of the kansas
city star this sunday
the front page of the kansas city star
this sunday two young men in the prime
of their life
high school-aged boys that died from
overdose of fentanyl
we all should realize that a teaspoon of
fentanyl could kill one or two thousand
people
these young men i don't know if they
took half a tablet if they took one
tablet but that would be plenty to make
most people stop breathing
in the past three months kansas has had
two thousand five hundred drug overdoses
last month wichita police officers on a
routine traffic stop picked up somebody
with seven thousand fentanyl pills and
again each one of those pills could
probably kill several people
we've apprehended since joe biden was
sworn in over six tons of fentanyl
seized at the border i drive a dodge ram
truck i could back my truck up and fill
that
10 or 12 times and that's how much we've
seized and we could assume that
multiples of that have got across the
border
i think the only conclusion is like i
said that this administration is either
incompetent or they want this crisis
thank you
i think one of my democratic colleagues
had it right the other day they said the
administration's efforts to roll back
title 42
shows a lack of understanding about the
crisis
at our border unquote
now the white house says this issues
about
public health concerns about the
pandemic but the biden administration
only seems to be concerned about the
pandemic when it supports their liberal
agenda
now according to the administration the
pandemic continues on airplanes
where they continue to fight for a
masked mandate
the pandemic continues in the halls of
congress
where the administration continues to
lobby for billions of dollars in
emergency relief funds
but on the border
they say the pandemic's over
come on
immigration officials have warned that
letting title 42 expire will make our
border crisis
three times worse
three times worse after
a year where we had two million
illegal border crossings
we know it needs to be done the
administration needs to stop playing
games
they need to do what's right for the
country they need to enforce the law and
they need to do what a bipartisan
majority of united states senators is
now calling for
keep title 42 in place
and secure the border
so last week i was in del rio i was in
del rio i was in eagle pass and
went down to see our north dakota
guardsmen we have 125 guardsmen down
there also in evoldi
and they're the eyes and ears of the
border patrol so it was down there to
support them and again call attention to
the crisis that is going on at the
border now it's interesting um last year
i was down there with cornyn and cruz we
had 16 senators and we were just to the
east in the rio grande sector del rio
sector is immediately to the west
the rio grande sector has been the
busiest sector now remember 220 000
uh illegal encounters by border patrol
just in the last month in march okay 1.7
million last year and that doesn't even
count
the gatoways
okay
and what's going on is at the time we
were there the rio grande sector was the
busiest now that's becoming the del rio
sector because they're migrating over
there because they have
many fewer border patrol
officers in the del rio sector
so they move where there's the least
resistance
senator portman myself we were in mexico
last year in central america we're in
south america
it's a demand pull situation because in
mexico and central america and south
america
they know if they come they're getting
in
so they're coming and interestingly
last year when we were in the rio grande
sector they said people were coming from
50 different countries 50 different
countries last year
this year just last week when i was in
del rio they said a hundred different
companies countries so customs and
border protection gave us a briefing and
they said that's gone from 50 different
countries people illegally crossing the
southern border now from a hundred
different countries
think about that
yeah the numbers are staggering and
remember when when you get those numbers
from homeland security they talk about
220 000 encounters with people crossing
the border illegally in the month of
march that doesn't count the guidaways
which can be maybe 40 percent more and
those are the folks that don't want to
be encountered why because they have
criminal records they have drugs they're
human trafficking that's what's going on
and if the administration lifts public
order 42 it just gets worse
it just gets worse when i was down there
we had two guardsmen from the north
dakota national guard uh specialist
alvaredo specialist clem who had just
saved five migrants who were trying to
cross at del rio they were out there
they were the rivers high the current is
strong there were five migrants that
probably would have drowned they went
out and they got them and they saved
them at great risk to their
themselves
and we know what that risk is because we
saw what happened to a texas national
guard
here just this week he drowned out there
trying to save migrants crossing illegal
who were trafficking drugs
that's a tragedy
that's a tragedy why is this
administration not stopping that
why is this administration not stopping
that
and we know it can be done the last
administration the trump administration
did it
you enforce public you keep public
health order 42 in place you enforce the
third safe country protocol and the
remain in mexico protocol
and you build the border wall
and we can secure that border
congress needs to push for it the courts
need to push for it and the public needs
to push for it we need to get the biden
administration
to enforce the law
and secure the border
i think there's a consensus among anyone
with any common sense that if we lift
title 42 is going to create a true
crisis
on the southern border that's what we've
been speaking of
it's going to create tremendous havoc
john mentioned the men and women that
work so hard on the border do a
tremendous job you can imagine the
strain that they're under now
but it's going to be unimaginable what
they're going to be facing
the other thing is it's going to put
tremendous pressure throughout all of
our government agencies i'm blessed i'm
a senior member on the
senate
veterans affairs committee i'm also the
ranking member on
military construction and veterans
appropriations
i've been through countless hearings
countless visits with va leadership
regarding the
lack of resources that we have right now
due to the labor shortages needing
specialists
needing all kinds of different providers
the list goes on and on one of the
things i'm very concerned about there's
talk of
using the fourth mission this is the
idea that when you have a crisis
that the veterans administration then
can step in and provide resources
to help fill that void
this is going to be a crisis
but it's a abiding administration
manufactured crisis
americans veterans have given everything
for this country
we can't let the resources and personnel
that are supposed to be dedicated to
taking care of them get ripped away
because the president as an
administration have so badly mismanaged
our border security
an illegal immigration problem
they don't deserve it and we won't stand
for it thank you
i think it's pretty clear that everyone
that has spoken today
just wants president biden to do his job
and to protect americans
you know they this administration
is continuing to just wreak havoc on the
southern border you know it tells
americans that people that title 42 is
no longer necessary because covet's
behind us and in the same breath they're
asking for billions of dollars in more
coveted relief how hypocritical is that
you know
it is amazing that the bite
administration is ending the covet
emergency for illegal immigrants but is
filing a pill on a federal judge's order
to overturn the mass mandates on
airplanes trains and buses
it
eliminating title 42
the consequences that we know
that that will bring that you know one
million more people would cross the
border
in the first six
weeks
after title 42 is eliminated
that's what we're looking at
it will make this issue that is already
an unbelievable crisis
it will make it three times as bad as it
is now it is unreal that you've got an
administration that is actually
implementing this
and defending it
you know
shelly said why is west virginia so
concerned let me tell you why
mississippi is so concerned
interstate 10 and interstate 20 run
right through mississippi
this past week a driver was pulled over
and
you know
these law enforcement agents have such a
hard time but a driver was pulled over
and arrested a texas man for
transporting over three pounds of these
fentanyl pills that we're talking about
three pounds of this little pill and it
was right there in rankin county in
mississippi it's destroying lives it's
destroying families
our job is to protect americans our job
is to enforce american laws
so uh you know when it comes down to the
biden administration
just simply using covid as an excuse to
push through these liberal policies and
it just doesn't matter what it's doing
to the safety of americans it is
unbelievable we need to continue to have
these press conferences we know what's
in front of us
again we're just asking president biden
to do his job
to protect americans
and enforce the laws that have already
been passed
cindy thank you
questions
some
comments
your democratic colleagues aren't
necessarily opposed to lifting title 42
rather
lifting it without a plan now that there
has been a plan released by secretary
marcus yesterday are you worried that
some of your colleagues across the aisle
are going to switch
over their sides if you've had any
conversations with them what are you
hearing so it's a great question i have
not heard that
but i wouldn't be surprised
the problem is it's not really a plan
and you know we looked at it carefully
yesterday we had a briefing on it
and primarily what it does is it
expedites
the immigration process as an example
instead of having processing at the
border there would be processing on the
bus or other means of transportation
going further into the interior to take
pressure off the border
as an example there would be more people
hired to process people more quickly
but nothing with regard to slowing the
flow
so i i it's it's it's not a plan that
deals with
this crisis
which is getting
of course far worse
than that
about 50 of people were turned away
so this this line would have been up
here if 42 had not been in place
and uh so i i mean that's the decision i
guess my colleagues have to make on the
other side of the aisle i think 11
members have said they have some
concerns with revoking title 42 at this
point the other point i would make is
this is not about title 42
ultimately that's going to go away at
some point kobit will be behind us we
won't have a public health emergency
we'll be left with a policy that doesn't
work
and we know what works because here
as you can see we have effective control
uh by putting in place some sensible
policies
um
the asylum policy changes that center
capital and others talked about is one
thing we have to do that actually was
not done
during the last administration that
would even lower those numbers further
which is to say immediate education if
somebody doesn't qualify they'd be sent
home
and that 85 percent of the people
who are applying from mexico or central
america or other places
are in the end not being granted asylum
and yet during the united states for six
to eight years uh and embedded in the
communities and so on so there's we know
it works
and and that's the kind of policy we're
looking for
my question is for senator cruz you
mentioned that uh leader schumer was
blocking a vote on having the senate go
on record with whether they support
delaying or
keeping title 42 in place
what's the best
legislative avenue at this point to keep
it in place i know that there's also
bipartisan legislation from senator
lankford and senator cinema at this
point
look i would be happy with any vehicle
that is moving
there was a couple of weeks ago before
the recess we were initially going to
vote on their
supplemental funding for
so-called coveted relief
and many of us were conditioning that
that vote on voting on title 42 and
schumer ultimately pulled it down he
supports the bill he wants to pass
but not at the price of actually having
a vote on title 42
and and my point is if if you know
democrats could have come to this press
conference there are no democrat
senators standing here so i get that the
ones up for re-election are putting out
press statements
claiming that they don't want to end it
but when they voted on it
every single one 100 of them
voted against preserving title 42.
do republicans can see that this is no
longer really about public health
because republicans have been very vocal
about rescinding all other pandemic
related restrictions but title 42 was
ostensibly put forward as a public
health measure so if if you don't
support mass mandates right and a host
of others then
how do you can justify continuing to
support title 2 look mask mandates are
the height of hypocrisy and by the way i
will say on masked mandates if you look
on any airplane people are voting with
their faces
vast majority of people on planes the
instant the mandate was repealed pulled
them off i gotta say i'm actually
pleasantly comforted even in the capitol
hill press corps which i think is fair
to say is not a right-wing organization
the large majority of reporters in this
room
made the choice and voted voted with
your faces not to wear the mask
listen
the crisis here ultimately is about the
deliberate chaos and human suffering at
the border
when we had the lowest rate of illegal
immigration in 45 years under donald
trump it wasn't title 42 that was
driving it it was the remaining mexico
agreement it was enforcing the laws the
reason for this chaos
is joe biden and kamal harris made the
political decision not to enforce the
laws to release vast numbers of illegal
aliens and with title 42 they want to
release much more you know i was looking
at
one of them
so if you are against coven
look i'm against an unsecured border i'm
against the chaos
uh you know
one estimate
is that if title 42 is rescinded
permanently 170 more thousand more
illegal aliens will come through our
southern border that's a massive number
we had 221
303 come across our southern border last
month alone
and that's that's in a month yeah that's
not an annual year that's that's a month
if joe biden follows through
with rescinding title 42
we will see the highest rate of illegal
immigration in the history of the united
states of america that is their desired
outcome and on covid the utter hypocrisy
of it
look when you say it's not about public
health let me encourage you come down to
south texas visit the hospitals in
laredo that are full
or in mcallen that are full
visit the schools that are full come to
the biden cages
for four years every democrat and and
the corporate press talked about kids in
cages kids in cages how many of y'all
have done a story on the biden cages
what you didn't report on is barack
obama built those cages
the cages are more full today under joe
biden than they ever have been and the
last time we went there with 19 senators
the rate of covet positivity in the
biden cages was over 10 percent so this
is public health as well
but the biden administration the only
group on planet earth they don't care
about having covid is illegal immigrants
who they want to release into this
country so you're saying it's not about
kobe then
the the rollback of title 42 you're
saying it's about immigration about both
because title 42 as my colleague says is
implemented as a covid measure yeah let
me let me let me take a crack at this
also because uh as i said earlier
title 42 is not going to be there into
the future
it's a public health quarter it
shouldn't be
you know once we're beyond this coveted
period
which is all the more reason we have to
put in place sensible policies to deal
with this crisis title 42 is not the
long-term solution it's not sustainable
it's just we all know that for now to
address it's not convenient it's it's
the fact that it's all there is
if we don't have it if we if we don't
have it there will be so there are two
million people come to the border now
every year based on last year's numbers
which is
the highest it's ever been
since 1924 when the border patrol
started keeping statistics
by far the highest ever if title 42 is
lifted
think about it instead of two million
and a million people coming into the
country you have just by by math now two
million people coming into the country
and there are a lot more people coming
also as you've seen all over the world
it's not just central america
this chart which is interesting i think
because it talks about outside of mexico
in the northern triangle
the increase coming it's 150 countries
it's people from
not just latin america but asia and
africa and the middle east
so that is why taking away 42 would be a
catastrophe right now but it's going to
have to go away that's why
the administration needs to put in place
a policy behind it this is what these 11
democrats are saying to your question
you can't pull 42 without
something in in the alternative
something to replace it or else you have
total chaos
and that's what we're not seeing and the
and the proposal to deal with it we
heard about yesterday again is more to
facilitate the vast increase in numbers
rather than to deal with the numbers
and it's not fair
it's not fair to these countries in
central america and latin america and
really around the world who as we talked
john hoeven talked about being in mexico
central america and latin america with
him last year the presidents of these
countries who met with all four of them
all said the same thing you guys are
drawing our people north with your
policies
your asylum policy is a magnet stop
doing that it causes us problems we
don't want to lose all these people
first of all
but second of all you know with the the
migrant caravans and so on coming
through stop it change your policies put
in place sensible policies that's all
we're asking for but in terms of those
besides the sensible policies are there
any immigrants that your party can
support at this point you know what i
mean like there's uh
i mean
we're strong
we're strongly in support of legal
immigration immigration we're strongly
in support of legal immigration strong
and what in what policy during this
congress have republicans done anything
to support legal immigration well we we
we strongly support legal immigration
period i mean america is the most
generous country in the world in terms
of bringing illegal immigrants we're for
that i think i speak for for all my
colleagues do you support for example in
the competes act the provisions to offer
say the most non-controversial
immigrants of all stem phd's a green
card we're getting we're hearing from
your colleagues all week that you know
this is going to be too controversial
for this republican party
is the republican party at this point
just a restrictionist party no no i i
would support that of course and i
always have you staple the green card to
the diploma
senator bozeman's got to go you want to
say something
the only thing i would remind is
we have these numbers
but as somebody that used to be the
chair of homeland security these numbers
indicate people that are caught
it doesn't count the hundreds of
thousands of people because the border
guard is so tied up
doing things that they're not trained to
do taking care of young children things
like that you've got hundreds of
thousands of others that are going
across the other thing i'd remind people
is the border is secure on the mexican
side the cartels don't allow anybody to
cross without getting a cut of the
a cut
so it's a tremendous money maker for the
drug influx that we're so very concerned
about that's been talked about earlier
but senator does the increase in
apprehensions have anything to do with
the increase of appropriations as a
as a former chair of the appropriations
committee
as you increase appropriations for the
border wouldn't that result in more
apprehensions
no i'm for i'm all for
uh you know
plussing up border security yeah but
that would be good but that would make
that charge
no
because you actually you know when i was
chair we were actually able to
do things concerning building the wall
things like that putting in security
measures all of those kind of things
so you can do this
in a number of different ways the point
is it needs to be voted
and remember the objective of securing
the border is to deter people coming
illegally deterrence works there's a
reason we got to those low numbers
there's a reason the numbers
exploded the moment joe biden get there
and by the way apprehension for most of
these is is a term that's actually not
accurate
i would encourage all of you come down
to the border and see see what happens
because they literally they come across
the border they look for a border patrol
agent they turn themselves in they're
not being caught
the vast majority of them are not trying
to run they're not trying to escape they
come in and they go seek out a border
patrol border patrol
now put signs here here's where you get
processed and the reason is
because joe biden and kamal harris when
they get here they show up and they have
a phone number of someone in the united
states they have a place they want to go
and the biden administration is the last
mile of the human trafficking network
and they they put them on a bus and put
them on a plane and take them to
wherever they want to go in the country
and so these are not apprehensions the
objective is to deter people from
crossing illegally we know how to do it
and it's a very simple thing
you enforce the law
what joe biden and kamal harris won't do
is enforce the law let's take two more
questions speaking speaking of
deterrence and you had mentioned this
earlier about the current immigration
system does need to be reformed as far
as asylum processing adjudication so
would you agree with the dhs on that
point that you guys do need to do
something to reform the immigration
process or do you think that if the
administration implemented deterrence
policies that the current immigration
system would be enough to
would work well
well on the report uh that was issued
yesterday that james lankford had um you
will see it says something interesting
it says our current immigration policy
is broken
and yet there's no proposal to fix it so
absolutely we want to work with them on
that but that's not what they're
proposing
with regard to asylum the only proposal
that they've had
and this came out about a month ago was
to put asylum
officers on the border
to do an initial screen
but when that individual was deemed not
to be eligible
for asylum because they didn't meet the
standard of credible fear
then that person would be able to
immediately appeal to an immigration
judge
so in effect it only created another
bump in the road in other words
another time delay as opposed to the
policy that i would support
and senator cornyn and senator cinema
have legislation that goes along these
lines which is to actually
provide the funding to provide an
immigration adjudication with regard to
asylum at the border
immediately
and if that person doesn't qualify and
remember 85 percent roughly the people
who go through the system in the end
don't qualify
then those people would go back to their
country
uh that would have an
immediate deterrent effect so you would
agree that deterrence wouldn't be the
only solution it would need to be a kind
of a double
paper well that is deterrence i mean
it's deterrence because um when your
neighbor
comes back and reports you know what
they've got a system in place now where
you can't go in illegally
you can only go in if you're legal and
you wait in line
and again we have the most generous
system in the world and we support that
or you have to really be someone who
does have a legitimate fear of
persecution in your home country and
therefore you qualify
essentially as an asylum refugee
that would send a huge signal that's
what's going to stop people from coming
and then all the other provisions we
talked about here today that add a
further deterrent such as providing the
border patrol the tools they need with
the technology and the and the fencing
and the walls and
you know they when the biden
administration came in on day one they
stopped the construction of the wall
fine
they also stopped the construction of
all the technology that went with the
wall
and what my colleagues can tell you who
have been down there in the del rio
sector as an example since that was
talked about or el paso
they not only didn't complete the wall
they stopped the technology
in fact in del rio
in el paso
the technology was stopped after about
10 percent completion the wall was about
90 complete
now even my democrat colleagues support
technology i'm told
this is sensors and cameras and so on
but they stopped at all so there's a lot
of things you can do but ultimately if
you don't fix the asylum system you can
continue to have people drawn to our
border because they know as senator cruz
has said they can they can walk in
one more question then we'll be breaking
up this or i'll stick around as will
senator cruz i'm sure for questions
has been returned uh and
he should never have been detained in
russia we're glad he's back we're
we're glad that uh
he's gonna be back home in texas and and
we are celebrating that
one more question
since that wasn't yeah
can i ask about expedited removal um
on expedited removal one of the pieces
in the dhs memo was to increase these
effects guided removal with the thought
that a formal deportation order is going
to be more of a deterrence as you
mentioned to repeat crossers who right
now don't face illegal consequence
there's no disincentive to just keep
trying and if you look at the chart even
you sort of start to see a small rise
starting in april 2020 when title 42 is
lifted for title 42 is imposed
i was just wondering what your response
was to the recidivism concerns about
title 42 and whether you support
expanding expedited removal or do you
just see that as processing people
faster
yeah i think expert removal has to be
part of any policy that works
you know under the obama administration
there was about
as you know there were more people who
were deported through expedited removal
roughly 65 percent of those who came in
illegally were removed
the numbers we have for
the biden administration which would be
last fiscal year the eight months of the
biden administration it's roughly four
percent
so there's a huge difference even
between the obama years and the biden
years in terms of using expedited
removal and actually deporting people
who did not qualify to be in the united
states
and it's it's a further example of what
we're talking about is there's been a
there's been a
deliberate attempt through policy to
change what we're doing at the border
and also with regard to the interior
with regard to expedited removal and and
deportations
and this is this is part of the magnet
so title 42 were rescinded and
in its place was a very robust expedited
removal system where a high percentage
of people were removed through that
process so there is somewhat of a
process but it's well yeah again
the one caveat here which is a huge one
is that if you come to the border and
you claim asylum
you are permitted to come in
well if you pass credible fear if you
pass credible fear but that's that's a
very low bar as you know at the border
extremely low bar
so and then you go through the process
and then at the end of the process
you know roughly 15 percent are deemed
to have qualified
but meanwhile all all these other folks
are in the country
and so you have to deal with that issue
as well not just expedited removal and
then when that happens
is the person deported or not right now
again the five percent figure that that
is not happening so it's a big change in
terms of even the obama years until this
administration much less from the trump
administration to now
you come senator can i ask quickly
you care deeply about the board you also
hear deeply about ukraine and we're
expecting a supplemental request
um do you see that as an opportunity
you we heard senator thune say you want
to vote on this is that going to be an
opportunity to have a vote especially
considering it seems democrats want to
combine covet and ukraine
supplementals
yeah
my strong
desire is to keep ukraine separate
and if democrats decide they aren't
going to keep it separate
what does that mean
the ukraine supplemental
is a desperate need if we don't provide
it right now you'll see many more people
who die in ukraine
and it's totally non-partisan
i don't know i don't know i certainly
couldn't if you didn't have title 42 and
then you would lose a lot of democrats
so let's not play college there's no
point without title 42 anything with
coverdays or not
i don't think so i mean
um it would be a choice by democrats
ukraine
yeah which we can't do i mean this is
this is a
an urgent
desperate need right now to continue to
provide ukrainians what they need to
defend themselves
intensifying each other's unboxings
we have to at least give them the chance
to survive
okay